[Music]
Bachelorette beckons journey has also
just begun and we were exclusively on
set of her rosy nude photoshoot and
that's where ethion lines lauren zima
got her reaction to re the latest
breakup confessions re told us he's
gonna be watching your season i could
comfortably watch how do you feel
hearing that i figured we actually we
have had conversations from their slope
together like what do you think it could
be as the next Bachelorette so i figured
he would watch the show so becca
expected that what she didn't see coming
was Ari's excuses for the most
cringe-worthy event in bachelor history
you know those 25 uncut minutes of him
breaking up with her fans caught it
unnecessary and cruel so you're really
you're perfect like everything about
this I feel like doing it on camera
would just let everyone know that that
decision was solely mine okay we kind of
get it but Ari claims he had another
reason for doing what he did honestly I
wanted her the opportunity to be the
potential Bachelorette what's news to me
they don't think you ever expected me to
be entered how everything played out so
let's just say I don't know Becca it's
currently in production on her season of
The Bachelorette here's what we know
about night one she's wearing a gorgeous
white beaded gown there's a guy in a
chicken suit and one man bun we also
know there is at least one date coming
up that required protective gear
so clearly the twenty-seven-year-old
publicist is over her ex but is she
ready for another go-round
I wanted to be the best damn background
I can be and so I'm so excited he's
certainly got a lot of people pulling
for well the Bachelorette premiere is
May the 28th on ABC
[Music]